what's going on my name is Jay and in
this video I want to show you how you
can use a public API so let's see so for
this video we're gonna be using open
weather map dot org
they have a very very simple API they
have a ton of data that we can use so if
you go there and then you click API you
will see all these options right here
but the one that I want is this one the
first one the current and weather data
that's the one that I want okay so click
Subscribe you will see all these options
I'm the one that we're gonna use is the
free version which is gonna work for
this video any words for like a personal
website and stuff like that so click on
the get API key and start so you need to
sign up just like a normal website does
your email and password and all that
stuff and they're gonna give you an API
key so that way you can request all that
data so let's test the API so let's see
if it works I have here the URL that
they provide which is this one right
here alright so now we need to add
question mark Q equals to whatever CD
and you can see that I have it already
there so I live in Orlando so it's
Orlando and then and app have ID equals
to whatever API key they gave you all
right so that's mine don't try to use
mine because it's not gonna work for you
I'm gonna hit enter and here you go so I
have all the data from the current
weather in Orlando which is great one
thing that I want to do right now is
because if you can see here on
temperature that's a is a different unit
we use a different unit so I'm just
gonna put it right here after this and
so it's gonna be unit
equals to Imperial and then and and I'm
gonna leave the app ID so I'm gonna hit
enter again and now we have whatever you
use you can change it but this is what
we're use in the United States cool now
that we have this URL ready to go I'm
just gonna go to my text editor and
start coding here I have an HTML file
the only thing I have is requesting
jQuery who's gonna we gonna use it to
request the data we have a script D is
which is empty and we have a style dot
CSS is empty we're gonna add some stuff
in a minute so let's start by adding
some HTML here so the first thing I'm
gonna do I'm gonna add our container
everything's gonna be inside that
container so it can be like whether
container okay and inside there we can
do a paragraph and then we can add like
a class off this can be actually you
know what first I'm gonna add an icon
like if it's raining if it's raining we
can do like a rain cloud with some drops
or whatever if it's sunny we can add you
know a Sun or something like that so
that's the icon will just put icon as a
class this is gonna be like the name so
if it's raining is gonna be like rain if
you're sunny is gonna be sunny so this
is we can name it name it um I don't
know whether whatever
you can name it whatever you want so
let's create another one and this one is
gonna be a temperature of course time
all right cool I think that's all we
need for now
I like if I wonder whether I just want
like you know whatever is happening in
the and the temperature and then the
icon is something cool you know that we
like to see all right so that's it for
the HTML I'm gonna save it and then for
djao script let's go here because we
have jQuery we can use something called
get JSON and get JSON is going to get
all these data for us because this is
Jason this is JSON file so let's go back
there and let's do
I'm dollar sign dot get JSON just like
this and then we're gonna do inside here
we're gonna do the URL coma and then
function sorry function just like that
all right so we need to include that URL
here let's go back and get it where is
it here is copy pasted right there
alright so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
put here
inside the function I'm gonna put data
all the data is gonna be inside there
song I can do something like console log
data so I'm gonna save that and let's go
back here so this is my page right now
I'm gonna reload my page and here you go
we can see all the data the same thing
we have here we can see it we have it
now available for us on the website
everything is here
alright cool now that
working let's go back and hear inside
the function we're gonna do like let's
create the variable of the icon so let's
do variable icon and I have a URL that
they provided for everyone to get the
icon so if we go here let's see if they
have here on whether so you can see that
there is a icon here and there is like a
number in a letter you don't understand
how we're gonna use this in a minute so
they provided a URL for that icon so
let's see
let's open here and let's go back and
what was the code is what 11 D let's
copy and paste it dot PNG look at this
so every single thing is a different
thing depending on the weather the icon
is going to change and it's gonna be
this URL cool so let's go back to my
code
let's do whoops that's not what I want I
want the URL which is this and then I'm
gonna do plus and we need to add that
code which is gonna be data dot and
let's go here let's see so he's data dot
weather zero and then dot icon so these
data dot weather
zero and this is because it's an array
it's a list you can see that we have
oops quit we have zero one and it's an
array so we need to do square bracket
zero and then dot icon that's it now
we're gonna have if we call icon we're
gonna have this and then whatever code
it is and actually I need to add the PNG
file so the PNG format so let's go plus
sign and dot PNG now that's gonna work
there you go so now let me call the icon
and see if it works
also the log icon alright let's go back
let's reload this page here it is just
click on it and that's it we have the
icon alright so let's go back here so
that's working let's remove console.log
we don't need it
and now what I'm gonna do is I want to
add that icon inside this image so let's
do dollar sign we can that that the icon
class and then we're gonna do attribute
and then attribute is going to be this
source and that source inside that
source is gonna be the icon which is
hold this
all right cool let's save it
let's see that works let's reload the
page yay
we have here it seems like it's like
thunderstorms or something really bad is
going on here which is true like today
is a very rainy day so yes
all right cool so we have the icon dawn
so let's do the same thing with the
temperature so let's create another
variable let's call it temp equals 2 and
it's gonna be data dot I think is
whether dot temp yeah I think that's
that's what it is and this is gonna give
us that number so let's go back make
sure make sure that that's true all
right um now actually is main so I have
to fix that so we see main dot temp so
let's go back it's not weather is main
all right cool now we do the same thing
we're gonna go here and this is the dot
and the class temp but this time we're
gonna up hand
that data and this was gonna be time
let's say that and let's see what
happened that's it here we go we have we
have the temperature we have the icon
the temperature and I think we're
missing our weather text like it's
raining or it's not raining sunny what
what it is so let's go back and let's do
that let's do it right here in the
middle that way we are like organized so
variable we can create something called
weather or weather name or I don't know
whatever you want equals to data dot
weather let's go back and see where it
is so weather and then there's the Rays
I'm gonna get the first one and it's
gonna be thunderstorm okay so there is
thunderstorms
so weather 0.9 then we're gonna go down
here and want to do the same thing we're
gonna get the weather dot penned there's
a pend of data and it's gonna be weather
let's save it let's see what happens if
it if it works yeah there we go we have
the cloud it says that we have a
thunderstorm and is 86 now I don't want
to show this point four nine and point
forty nine I just want to show 86 and
there is a trick we can do it right here
on the weather no actually the
temperature sorry we can do math dot
floor
and let's see if the helps oops sorry
is math like this let us go cool now we
have only 86 all right so you don't have
to do the math floor actually there's
some other options um so I'm gonna put a
link in the description if you want to
play with this but I think that's it we
just need to kind of make it later
prettier because right now it looks very
very weird so let's go and let's add
some CSS so let's say um weather
container and let's do like a I don't
know like a gray background let's you
know what let's just align everything to
the center and we have the the weather
text the one that sets thunderstorm
right now let's do font size I'm like 22
pixels you know bigger and let's remove
all the margin because I know a
paragraph have like margin we have a
temp like the temperature we can do this
one I wanted like pretty big so let's do
like 60 pixels same thing margin zero
and whoops and the font weight I want it
to be bold
alright let's save that I think that's
that's good for now let's reload the
page and here it is so you have the icon
it said we have chunder storm and it's
86 so let's see what happens if we
change like Orlando to like New York for
exam
let's go in there let's go here let's
say you know what let's do something
real quick right here so we can do that
very easily so let's try a variable
called CD for example and right now is
Orlando and right now in the URL what we
can do is let's remove the name Orlando
we just closed the URL there we do plus
sign CD plus sign and then we open the
URL again
alright so now this is coming from this
variable okay so let's save it let's see
if it works
yep same thing so now let's change these
to like New York let's go there reload
the page here is so New York right now
75 clear seems like it's a beautiful day
so that's how you do it um you can go
very very complex and and use another
API that gets the user specific user
locations and then the city variable
will change depending on the location of
the person and all that stuff it can get
very complicated but this is a very very
simple way to get started and understand
how public API works not only weather
but there is a bunch of other api's with
other data that you can use in and you
can just is you can use it just like
this okay so that's it